to degree is a new start at this time
last year I announced a very
comprehensive plan to start to recover
and grow the business and whether that
be through and what we're going to do by
listening to customers putting them at
the heart of the business recovering our
clothing business continue to grow a
food business and transforming our
infrastructure and cost space it's about
making a business that's fit for the
future with sustainable profit growth
we've had to make some tough choices
we've closed our own international
business in Europe but we're making good
progress you've mentioned the words
recovery you're fed you knees put
customers at the heart of the business
does that mean you weren't doing that
before well I think it would be fair to
say that MLS has had lots of interaction
with customers but sometimes we not use
that interaction as well as we should
have done and we've talked to more than
3 million people we've analyzed more
than 5 million baskets we continue that
dialogue every day but we want to make
sure is we're really listening and
making sure we get exactly right for a
couple you used to lead the food part of
MMS which is that universal acclaim on
the other hand pretty much everyone has
so powders at a clothing division how
are you going to join these two parts
together well I think what we haven't
done is necessarily listening to our
customers hard enough and we need to
improve our values improve our quality
improve our fit and we've done that in
the last year and from September onwards
our new ranges have been reduced in
price and something like 27 percent the
ranges come down by 18 percent or more
we've simplified the ranges maybe easier
for customers to shop and we've improved
a fit on 70% of governments and our
now I think there are things that are
very common between the two businesses
the way we bring newness and innovation
in food is very similar to the way we
interpret fashion trends to compare
contemporary wearable garments and the
way we bring wardrobe staples to market
is very similar to the convenience
aspects of food but both businesses
underpinned by quality and we need to
eat we need to make sure the quality in
clothing was actually gone and over the
past few years it seems M&S has put a
lot of focus on producing women's wear
that's at the cutting edge of fashion do
you think that was a mistake did that go
too far well I think we went a little
bit too far in a fashion our customers
attenders they want to be see the
interpret fashion and turn those into
contemporary stylish clothes and
building great wardrobe essentials we
hadn't done enough of that and our
emphasis in the binary parks has been to
make sure we're improving those products
and better value and better ranging so
you're absolutely right
and you'll see more and more of that in
our stores as you as we go through the
next few months right now inflation is
outstripping wage growth in this country
how's that going to change the way that
you run Marks & Spencer the first thing
is that for retailers inflation ahead of
disposable income increases is not
recipe necessary good news and their
inflationary pressures on the consumer
wallet from all the all sorts of
directions the thing about Mark Spencer
is we've worked very hard to bring our
prices down we've actually reduced the
prices in clothing fairly substantially
we intend to maintain that now the issue
for us of course is how do we balance
that with the pressures on margin in
your business we've got to do a lot of
work on efficiency on better buying
improving our logistics but we think we
can do that and make sure we manage to
get the balance right between returns
for shareholders and
great value for customers you're
launching for their big effectively a
CSR program in community outreach
program wow what a big companies need to
carry I think what we want to do in the
next stage of panay and today is the
start of that is really start to engage
consumers and customers so that they can
make a difference to their environment
so our plan for the next ten years is to
give 10 million people healthier and
happier lives to transform with partners
a thousand commuters in the UK and to
create a business which is zero waste at
every level truly ambitious targets but
we want to get their ambitious target
but I like go back to the original
question which is why let's say I was
the most hard-nosed
shareholder you've got and I'd say
where's the return on his investment
well we think there's evidence not just
us but from other companies that
customers care and join in with
companies who have good corporate social
responsibility we know that underpinning
things like quality in our business
customers expect us to work with
integrity but also they want to be
engaged in their local community this
program we're hearing them today is
about engaging communities making a real
difference and a thriving community is
good for business how much should a
Vista you think is down to big companies
right yourself because not a feed
company and how much of this is stuff
that government should be doing well I
think with the pressures that are on
communities in the UK from all different
directions whether it be through
positive poverty whether it be isolation
will be loneliness whether it be mental
stress I don't think the problem is for
any one person to solve but I think that
business can play a part in making sure
that communities are thriving and I
think it's about getting together with
business local government charity
partners and people in the community and
together we will make a big difference